damen und herren die cyber
bedrohungslage in unserem lande ist
anhaltend hoch
der bericht zur lage der it-sicherheit
2020 belegten eindrucksvoll die zahl der
schadprogramme hat die milliardengrenze
überschritten
täglich gibt es 320.000 neue
schadprogramme versionen und die
angriffsmethoden werden immer
aggressiver insbesondere durch
erpressung von beteiligten
glücklicherweise ist uns in den letzten
tagen im kampf gegen die schadsoftware
ein großer erfolg gelungen
in der ukraine konnte ein
tatverdächtiger von spezialeinheiten in
seiner wohnung festgenommen werden
während er dort am rechner saß der
beschuldigte scheint kooperativ zu sein
zugangsdaten für die deaktivierung der
e-mail-infrastruktur com erlangt werden
die infizierten systeme kommunizieren
jetzt nicht mehr mit der täter
infrastruktur sondern mit einem bka
beweis sicherungssystem das ist
gleichbedeutend mit erfolgreichen
übernahme und zerschlagung weiter teile
der it-infrastruktur
so können wir die opfer im mittel
ansprechen und ihnen bei der bereinigung
ihrer systeme behilflich sein
das ist eine wirklich
das ist eine wirklich gute nachricht
ich bin sehr froh dass wir dies auch der
hervorragenden arbeit des
bundeskriminalamtes und der
zentralstelle zur bekämpfung der
internetkriminalität zu verdanken haben
die nämlich hier auch den dank
aussprechen möchte im auto zeigt wie
wichtig die it-sicherheit für uns alle
ist das erste it sicherheitsgesetz 2015
war bereits ein wesentlicher schritt für
die schaffung von mehr cyber und
it-sicherheit in deutschland ein hohes
schutzniveau erfordert aber gerade in
diesem bereich der sehr dynamisch ist
eine stetige anpassung an die rasanten
technischen entwicklungen mit dem
sicherheitsgesetz 20 dass wir heute in
erster lesung beraten stärken wir den
rechtlichen rahmen und setzten den
koalitionsvertrag um
der gesetzentwurf das möchte ich gleich
vorweg sagen enthält mehr als die
ohnehin wichtigen regelungen zu 5 g
erstens schutz der wirtschaft und der
allgemeinheit durch einen besseren
schutz der kritischen infrastrukturen
und kritischer komponenten und weitere
unternehmen im öffentlichen interesse
dem verbraucherschutz zweitens durch das
bsi und durch ein sicherheits
kennzeichen des bsi soll zunehmend die
funktion eines verbraucherschutzes für
alle übernehmen
und drittens der schutz der
bundesverwaltung durch kontrolle und
mindeststandards cybersicherheit der oft
diskutierten 5g mobilfunknetze sind die
zukünftigen
fazit nur autobahnen und sie bieten
zahlreiche chancen und anwendungsfelder
etwa bei der mobilität und bei der
fabrik der zukunft absicherung dieser
netze muss daher möglichst umfassend
gewährleistet sein
technische und nicht technische risiken
wären wir mit diesem gesetzentwurf ab
die netzbetreibern werden hohe
sicherheitsanforderungen vorgegeben
kritische komponenten müssen
zertifiziert werden
gesetzlich ist es gibt einen künftig ein
gesetzliches verfahren das die
überprüfung der vertrauenswürdigkeit der
hersteller ermöglicht und als ultima
ratio auch ex ante untersagung des
einsatzes bestimmter komponenten das
heißt untersagung vor einbauen
das war lange diskutiert das war lange
diskutiert und ich bin sehr froh dass
die bundesregierung dem parlament
diese weitreichenden vorschläge machen
kann
neben den kritischen infrastrukturen
sollen jetzt auch unternehmen erfasst
werden die für unser leben von zehn sind
unternehmen wie wir sie nennen im
gesetzentwurf im besonderen öffentlichen
interesse etwa unternehmen im
rüstungsbereich aber auch unternehmen
die besondere bedeutung für die
volkswirtschaft haben beispiel bei einem
großen deutschen autobauer stehen
aufgrund einer cyberattacke zwei wochen
lang die fließbänder still und das hat
natürlich auch die gesamtwirtschaftliche
bedeutung vertrauen meine damen und
herren ist eine schlüsselressource in
der cyber sicherheit
unternehmen sollen in einer
vertrauensvollen zusammenarbeit mit dem
bsi auf mehr sicherheit hin
der bessere information austausch
relevanter erkennungs muster für systeme
und überhaupt viele erkennen die
angriffe gar nicht zur angriffs
erkennung risiken zunehmend auch in
verbraucher haushalten zum beispiel
durch die vernetzung von geräten
internet der dinge als stichwort der
smarte lösung als weiter der kühlschrank
als weiteres stichwort mehr vernetzung
bedeutet nämlich mehr risiken weil etwa
geräte zu botnetzen zusammen geschaltet
werden
verbraucherschutz wird im
aufgabenkatalog unserer
bundesoberbehörde bsi verankert
verbraucher sollen von den freiwilligen
it sicherheits kennzeichen profitieren
dass die it sicherheit eines produktes
sichtbar macht für den verbraucher und
auf das er sich auch verlassen kann
beim kauf eines marken kühlschranks soll
der verbraucher also nicht nur den
energieverbrauch am energielabel sehen
können sondern auch die enthaltenen
cyber sicherheitsfunktionen und
schließlich und letztens noch der schutz
der bundesverwaltung ein ganz wichtiger
punkt wir konnten bisher alle angriffe
abwehren
das zeigt auch die hohe das hohe niveau
unserer bundes behörden und das soll
jetzt durch dieses gesetz noch stärker
gestaltet werden
ich möchte abschließend sagen die
letzten monate in der pandemie haben
unser allen deutlich vor augen geführt
wie wichtig sicherheit ist aber auch die
nutzung von it an stelle der
zettelwirtschaft und dass dieser
digitalisierung schub der jetzt ja auch
eingetreten ist dass der auch mit mehr
sicherheit verbunden wird mehr nutzung
braucht auch mehr sicherheit und deshalb
diese sicherheitsgesetz 20
ich bitte um ihre unterstützung und
schließlich dann auch um eine
rechtzeitige verabschiedung dieses
wichtigen gesetzes
vielen dank
das wort geht an julia nakötter von der
fraktion yanacocha ist digital
politische sprecherin ihrer fraktion
stadtpräsident sehen wir die kollegen
über zwei jahre warten wir jetzt auf das
sicherheitsgesetz 2.0 die bedrohungslage
bereich der it-sicherheit hat deutlich
zugenommen
der schutz von kritischen
infrastrukturen energie wasser
telekommunikation muss erhöht und den
neuesten entwicklungen angepasst werden
immer wieder haben wir von der
opposition nach dem stand des gesetzes
gefragt immer wieder wurden wir
vertröstet und jetzt kurz vor
weihnachten war es dann soweit und dann
müsste auch alles ganz schnell gehen
denn die last legislatur neigt sich dem
ende zu und so kam was kommen musste
für einen wirklich durchdachten
gesetzentwurf hat es nicht mehr gereicht
ich fühle mich an digital strategie der
bundesregierung erinnert auch hier kein
klares konzept keine definition von
schutzschilden zielen keine wirkliche
strategie zur verbesserung der
sicherheitslage
nur ein fröhliches nebeneinander
verschiedener behörden wünsche purer
aktionismus garniert mit ein bisschen
hilflosigkeit
dabei ist so einfach sein können
das allerwichtigste die evaluierung die
sicherheitsgesetze 1.0 dass wir von der
afg fordern
in der ersten fassung des gesetzes von
2015 ist diese vorgeschrieben doch das
haben sie in bekannter art einfach
ignoriert zu untersuchen was im ersten
gesetz funktioniert hat und was nicht
was sinn gemacht hat und was nicht wo
fehler gemacht werden wurden die wir
jetzt in der neuauflage verhindern
können das wäre wirklich sinnvoll
gewesen
doch entscheidungen aufgrund von exakten
daten und realitäten zu treffen das ist
anscheinend nicht so ihr ding werte
bundesregierung das haben sie auch beim
netzwerk durchsetzungs gesetz bewiesen
dass wurde verschärft bevor es evaluiert
wurde und damit man ihnen das beim
nächsten mal die sicherheitsgesetze
nicht wieder unter die nase reiben kann
haben sie die evaluierung jetzt einfach
ganz ausgelassen so kann man es auch
machen
die zweite chance die sie verpasst haben
ist die einbindung der
zivilgesellschaftlichen organisationen
sie haben einen tag gegeben um das
gesetz zu lesen und darauf zu reagieren
ein tag für ein gesetz das erhebliche
auswirkungen auf die wirtschaft haben
jetzt der chaos computer club nicht dass
eine gezielte sabotage demokratischer
prozesse
diabetes geht sogar noch weiter und
spricht von einem mittelfinger ins
gesicht der zivilgesellschaft beide
haben recht diese art des umgangs ist
ein unding meine damen und herren und
darf sich so nicht wiederholen
kommen wir zum bsi das bundesamt für die
sicherheit in der informationstechnik
wird durch dieses gesetz mit
weitreichenden befugnissen ausgestattet
und entwickelt sich zu einer art
polizeibehörde inklusive der lizenz zum
hacken dem aktiven eingreifen in die
sicherheit von unternehmen der
ausweitung von speicherung von
protokolldaten und der zurückhaltung von
informationen bezüglich
sicherheitslücken
all das sehen wir von der afg kritisch
gerade letzteres birgt große gefahren
der bewusst sicherheitslücken offen
lässt und behörden zugriff zu
verschaffen
gefährdet die gesamte it sicherheit
meine damen und herren solche lücken
müssen sobald sie ins weg wird so bald
entdeckt werden an die unternehmen
weitergegeben werden um maximale
sicherheit der it systeme zu garantieren
letzter punkt sie haben sie diesem
gesetz sehr bewusst vermieden eine klare
und endgültige politische entscheidung
darüber zu treffen ob staatsnahe
netzwerkausrüster aus undemokratischen
ländern am 5 g ausbau beteiligt werden
dürfen wie zb huawei wollen wir unsere
kritische infrastruktur wirklich in die
hände von den chinesen legen wenn wir
doch gute europäische alternativen haben
sie sind doch sonst immer für die eu
wieso nicht in diesem fall wo es
ausnahmsweise mal wirklich sinn machen
würde meine damen und herren liegt das
vielleicht daran dass wir weit ihre
parteitage sponsert liebe cdu und liebe
spd
fakt ist der vorgelegte gesetzentwurf
gefährdet einen schnellen und 60 jahren
ausbau der netze hier muss endlich eine
klare entscheidung getroffen werden
suchen sie noch ein bisschen vielleicht
bekommen sie den mut noch irgendwie vor
der entscheidung diese vor der
verabschiedung dieses gesetzes doch noch
eine klare entscheidung zu zeichnen
fazit das gesetz ist ein kessel buntes
die schnelligkeit mit der
zusammengeschustert worden ist merkt man
ihm deutlich an
wir sehen erheblichen
nachbesserungsbedarf und werden dem so
nicht zustimmen vielen dank
soweit die rede von johanna die digital
politische sprecherin der fdp-fraktion
hier der deutsche bundestag und der
nächste redner ist sebastian hartmann er
sitzt für die sozialdemokraten im
mitglied im ausschuss für innere
sicherheit
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin meine
lieben damen und herren liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen ein moderner
staat gewährt und sicherheit sicherheit
gerade der moderne demokratische
rechtsstaat sichert diese sicherheit
weil sie die voraussetzung für die
freiheit in unserem land ist und
deswegen wird mit zunehmender
verschmelzung von analoger und digitaler
sicherheit die bedeutung von it
sicherheit immer wichtiger
wir sind stolz darauf dass wir in
deutschland vor fünf jahren bereits das
sicherheitsgesetz 1.0 beschlossen haben
und dass wir in diesem koalitionsvertrag
vereinbart haben dass et
sicherheitsgesetz 2.0 vorzulegen
natürlich ist es lange überfällig dass
es zu einem update unseres
betriebssystems kommt dass wir eben auch
auf erfahrungen und entsprechende
gefahren in unserem rechtsstaat noch mal
neu reagieren können sind angesprochen
worden hunderte von millionen
schadprogramme die wirtschaft und
bürgerinnen und bürger bedrohen in
unserem land wir haben erlebt dass
arzneimittelbehörden europäischer ebene
angegriffen worden sind oder auch
unikliniken plötzlich vor der
herausforderung standen dass sie nicht
mehr sich um patientinnen und patienten
kümmern können umso wichtiger ist es
dass wir als koalition jetzt reagieren
und endlich das sicherheitsgesetz 2.0
vorliegt meine damen und es ist nicht so
dass daraus auch keine entscheidungen
vorausgegangen sind wir haben über die
monate beruhen und es ist etwas verkürzt
worden denn mancher öffentlicher debatte
als ob es ausschließlich um die
kritischen komponenten oder bestimmte
hersteller und ausrüster ding hier ist
ein gangbarer weg gefunden worden dass
man eben die technisch überprüft
ein kritischer komponenten klar trennt
von einer politisch strategischen
entscheidung für die ein deutscher start
auch einstehen muss auf europäischer
ebene weil wir europäische digitale
souveränität wollen meine damen und
herren
ein weiterer gedanke ist dass wir das
bundesamt für sicherheit in der
informationstechnik auch eine zentrale
rolle zuweisen die stärken der säule des
verbraucherschutzes hat hier besondere
bedeutung so geht s einher dass wir auch
hunderte von neuen stellen eingerichtet
haben dafür sorgen dass mehr mittel zur
verfügung stehen und dass
verbraucherinnen und verbraucher in
unserem land sich darauf verlassen
können dass bsi steht an ihrer seite und
wir sollten nicht vergessen dass ein
viertel aller deutschen statistisch
gesehen schon einmal opfer von cyber
kriminalität geworden sind meine damen
und herren der nächste gedanke ist dass
wir natürlich auch dafür sorgen müssen
dass nun das parlamentarische verfahren
beginnt hier schlägt die stunde des
parlaments
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen hier
kommen wir nun dann zu unserer
verantwortung und ich bin mir sehr
sicher
herr kollege von notz dass wir über
fragen welche fristen wir zum beispiel
brauchen wenn es um entsprechende
komponenten geht die verbaut werden oder
auch fragen wie wir den
verbraucherschutz noch stärken können
nun im parlamentarischen verfahren auch
unter einbeziehung der kritischen
konstruktiven und demokratischen
opposition sicher reden werden
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen kunden
grünen der fdp und den linken
dazu gehört aber auch dass wir dann im
hinweise aus der community ernst nimmt
die verbände die initiativen aber auch
die unternehmen haben sich entsprechend
positioniert und das mitten in der
parlamentarischen beratung auch eine
wesentliche rolle spielt es gilt das
gesetz aber eines sollten wir hier
gemeinsam vereinbaren
nachdem es so lange gebraucht hat ist
das parlament erreicht worden ist mit
diesem gesetz sollten uns darauf
verständigen dass es in dieser
legislaturperiode endlich zum
überfälligen update unseres
betriebssystems kommt das sind wir der
it-sicherheit schuldig da sind wir allen
bürgern
bürgern im land schuldig und denkt ist
ja auch an diejenigen die gerade wegen
corona den schub in der digitalisierung
erfahren haben sie müssen sich darauf
verlassen können dass wir nun uns darum
kümmern und damit haben wir eine gute
vorlage die in diesem parlament zur
beratung ansteht herzlichen dank wie
kann die kritische infrastruktur
gewährleistet werden wenn bestimmte
anbieter die it versorgung für diese
infrastruktur leisten darüber diskutiert
der deutsche bundestag und zu einem
entwurf der bundesregierung zur erhöhung
der sicherheit informationstechnischer
systeme manuel höferlin spricht jetzt
für die fdp-fraktion damen und herren
ich wurde gestern angesprochen dass wir
heute über das sicherheitsgesetz 2.0
entscheiden
man könnte fast den eindruck haben so
lange reden wir schon darüber dass der
eindruck besteht es läge jetzt etwas zum
schließen vorbei ist es jetzt
eingebracht endlich man könnte meinen
las lange währt wird endlich gut
ja sie haben richtig gesagt herr
innenminister die cybersicherheit ist
die achillesferse der modernen
gesellschaft der
informationsgesellschaft würde ich es
nennen und deshalb ist cyber sicherheit
auch wirklich wichtig aber so richtig
gut finden wir freie demokraten an
vielen stellen das alte
sicherheitsgesetz nicht vor allen dingen
das fehlen einer gewesen dinge und auch
die möchte ich jetzt gerne eingehen
drei punkte aber ich mir ausgesucht es
gibt noch mehr ein punkt und ich kann es
wirklich nicht verstehen sie haben es
nicht geschafft nach so langer zeit ein
echtes schwachstellenmanagement in einem
sicherheits gesetz zu verankern
es geht doch darum dass neben einer
meldepflicht auch zb ein rückkanal
aufgebaut wird das auch die unternehmen
etwas zurückkriegen informiert werden
außerdem und das fordern wir freie
demokraten schon lange dass alle
staatlichen stellen sicherheitslücken
schwachstellen in software den bsi
melden müssen diese auch dann den
herstellern gemeldet werden und zeitnah
geschlossen werden ansonsten
veröffentlicht das ist der einzige weg
cyber sicherheit herzustellen wenn sie
es wirklich ernst nehmen herr minister
dann das it sicherheits kennzeichen ich
würde mal sagen ich nehme es gerne auch
aufkleber auf software
lassen sie das kurz mal wirken alles was
wir haben auch die hardware wird ja mit
patches und updates permanent bespielt
und die sicherheitslücken entstehen
gerade dann haben ja gerade wieder
gemerkt in aktuellen
sicherheitsvorfällen wenn diese patches
eben schadsoftware enthalten
und deswegen reicht es eben nicht dass
die freiwillige sicherheits kennzeichen
machen in denen eben gesagt wird wird
schon alles gut haben sie doch mal den
mut eine produkthaftung für diese
hersteller herzustellen dass da am ende
wenn die grob fahrlässig obwohl sie es
zugesagt haben keine updates und keine
patches auf spielen eben auch haften für
den schaden das wäre etwas was die
cybersicherheit voranbringen würde meine
damen und herren und zuletzt das bsi sie
haben uns auf ihrer seite wenn sie das
bsi zu einer der zentralen freibad
sicherheitsstellen in deutschland
ausbauen wollen sie haben den letzten
fünf jahren personal aufwuchs massiv
vorangetrieben zu recht ist verdoppelt
kann man sagen seit fünf jahren glaube
ich wenn ich es im kopf habe aber das
bsi gerät zunehmend in die schere
zwischen schließen von sicherheitslücken
und in ihrem haus herr minister das
offenhalten für sicherheitslücken und
staatstrojaner online durchsuchen et
cetera weiter durchsetzen zu können
spielt keine rolle ob sie das bag tor
oder front tonnen am ende geht es darum
dass dies nicht das cyber sicherheit
dient nehmen sie das bsi endlich aus dem
bmi raus wir werden vorschlagen sie
wissen dass unter 1 digital ministerium
da gehört hin dass sind die nerds unter
sich und können die cyber sicherheit am
ende gewährleisten meine meine damen und
herren wir drei demokraten werden das
sicherheitsgesetz positiv begleitet sie
werden eine zahlreiche antrags von
änderungsanträgen von uns bekommen
schreiben sie sie ab fügen sie ein damit
das sicherheitsgesetz am ende so gut
wird dass die dinge die fehlen auch noch
drin sind herzlichen dank für ihre
aufmerksamkeit
während der bundestag hierüber die
sicherheit informationstechnischer
systeme diskutiert geht es ein paar
flores weiter hier um die gescheiterte
pkw maut da tag nämlich der
untersuchungsausschuss und als letzter
zeuge ist übrigens
bundesverkehrsminister andreas scheuer
geladen
von ihm erwarten wir auch in den
nächsten minuten ein statement wenn es
so weit ist geben wir dann auch zeitig
rüber so dass sie schon mal bescheid
wissen erst mal bleiben wir aber hier
mit anke domscheit berg deshalb ist
dieses gesetz ja so wichtig und deshalb
ist es unerträglich dass die
bundesregierung es so in den sand setzt
schon sein entstehungsprozess war ein
problem
völlig zu recht gab es harte kritik aus
der zivilgesellschaft ich zitiere das
war ein stinkefinger ins gesetz ins
gesicht der demokratie weil nämlich ein
gesetzentwurf über ein jahr herum lag
dann für die leg für den letzten von
vier entwürfen die in vier wochen kamen
nur 24 stunden zur kommentierung für
zivilgesellschaft wissenschaft und
wirtschaft bereit stand und keine
einzige änderung markiert war als selbst
keinen änderungsbedarf version 1 das
gesetz ist eine evaluation unter
einbeziehung wissenschaftlicher
sachverständiger vorgeschrieben und das
neue gesetz kommt trotzdem ohne die
bundesregierung macht dieses neue gesetz
ohne ahnung zu haben
ob die maßnahmen im ersten satz
überhaupt zur it sicherheits erhöhung
beitragen oder eben nicht als
linksfraktion fordern wir faktenbasierte
politik und eine zeitnahe evaluation
wenn das einzige ziel dieses
gesetzentwurfes wäre die vertraulichkeit
integrität und verfügbarkeit von
it-systemen sicherzustellen
dann müssten sich ja unsere
langfristigen forderungen darin finden
das bsi endlich unabhängig vom bmi und
seinen geheimdiensten zu machen und das
bsi müsste endlich verpflichtet sein
jede einzelne gefundene sicherheitslücke
sofort an die hersteller zu melden damit
sie geschlossen werden aber bei das ist
immer noch nicht der fall
es geht gar nicht nur um die
widerstandsfähigkeit der it
gegenangriffe es geht auch um die
befähigung der geheimdienste gefundene
sicherheitslücken für überwachung des
tätigkeiten ausnutzen zu können
die bundesregierung unterwandert damit
weiterhin unsere an
it-sicherheit und das lehnen wir
entschieden ab aber auch im detail mit
der gesetzentwurf am ziel vorbei so ist
das geplante sicherheits kennzeichen
völlig überflüssig sinnlos und kein
beitrag zum verbraucherschutz
es ist überflüssig denn in paragraf 9a
steht bereits die umsetzung eines
europäischen kennzeichens warum denn
dann ein deutsches sonder kennzeichen
und der paragraf 19
es ist auch sinnlos denn es ist
freiwillig und ganz anders als sie herr
seehofer behaupten gibt es keine chance
künftig für verbraucher unsichere
produkte zu erkennen und bei ihrem
beispiel zu bleiben dann gibt es nämlich
nur noch kühlschränke auf den aaa + + +
steht war alle anderen gar kein label
haben niemand erklärt sein eigenes
produkt freiwillig für unsicher das
kennzeichen basiert außerdem nur auf
selbsterklärung der hersteller und eine
prüfung erfolgt nur anhand der
plausibilität eingereichter papiere nur
manchmal optional gibt es eine prüfung
ob die selbsterklärung überhaupt den
tatsachen entspricht nach dem cyber
security act der eu hätte das
kennzeichen damit völlig zu recht die
vertrauens stufe niedrig dieses gesetz
herr seehofer ist eine einzige
sicherheitslücke als linksfraktion
werden wir das nicht mittragen
im übrigen gehören informationen zu
schwangerschaftsabbrüchen nicht ins
strafrecht § 92a gehört abgeschafft
vielen dank
[Applaus]
soweit anke domscheit-berg sie sehen
schon hier bild im bild wir warten auf
das statement von bundesverkehrsminister
andreas scheuer der hier im
untersuchungsausschuss zur geplatzten
maut gesprochen hat heute er wird in den
nächsten minuten erwartet jetzt aber
erstmal konstantin von notz kolleginnen
und kollegen vom stücks netzangriff 2010
soll er ins jetzt gerade auch der
minister hat gesagt im bereich der
it-sicherheit brennt die hütte
lichterloh
sie brennt lichterloh und darauf weisen
wir hier seit vielen jahren aus der
opposition hin und was hat die
bundesregierung die letzten zwei jahre
gemacht nichts sie haben nicht geliefert
meine damen und herren statt zu
regulieren und standards zu setzen haben
sie vollkommen sinnfreie 5g diskussion
über einzelne anbieter geführt
sie halten an den instrumenten der
massenüberwachung fest und sie handeln
und hehlen selbst mit sicherheitslücken
wer so agiert der dokumentiert sein
eigenes unverständnis bei den
drängendsten einem der drängendsten
sicherheitspolitischen themen unserer
zeit meine damen tragen dem start kommt
eine direkte verantwortung eine pflicht
für den schutz der digitalen
infrastrukturen zu sie agieren nicht
dementsprechend sollen sie tun das
gegenteil das bmi ist es hier mehrfach
gesagt worden sinniert über das
aufbrechen von kryptographie
während sie den bürgerinnen und bürgern
sonst
allen sonntagsreden sagen ihr müsst
verschlüsseln reden sie über das brechen
von verschlüsselungen sie schreiben
überall vorratsdatenspeicherung rein
obwohl es europarechtswidrig ist dass es
kontraproduktiv das hilft niemandem
weiter meine damen und herren
deswegen ist ihre bilanz in dem bereich
verheerend verheerend wir brauchen eine
kehrtwende und jetzt kommen sie hier in
der letzten legislatur in dieser letzten
kurve dieser legislatur kommen sie hier
mit diesem gesetzesentwurf erarbeitet
der ist eben diese konsequente
kehrtwende nicht nur ein beispiel
kollege höfen ihn angesprochen das bsi
bauen sie aus zu einer art ersatz
nachrichtendienst dabei müssten sie es
unabhängig stellen
aber ich habe herr kollege hat man viele
andere gute vorschläge die sich jetzt
alle aufnehmen werden habe ich
verstanden
wir brauchen klare zuständigkeiten
innerhalb der bundesregierung neue
strukturen zur erkennung hybrider
bedrohungslagen wir brauchen
rechtsgrundlagen zum beispiel für die
zusammenarbeit im cyber-abwehrzentrum
wir brauchen die meldepflicht für
sicherheitslücken wir brauchen eine
durchgehende
ende-zu-ende-verschlüsselung neue
haftungsregelungen weniger
massenüberwachung mehr freie offene und
offene software und so der ins zeigt wir
brauchen endlich klare vorgaben bei der
zertifizierung beim erstellen und
verbauen von software all das bleiben
sie hier heute schuldig nach zwei jahren
stillstand meine damen und herren so
geht es nicht
wir haben zu all diesen dingen sachen
vorgelegten sie haben es geschafft
innerhalb ihrer kurz gesetzten fristen
alle verbände maximal auf die palme zu
bringen so muss man es erst mal
hinkriegen so desaströs bei dem
wichtigen thema wir stehen trotzdem für
konstruktive gespräche zur
verfügung aber ich sage ihnen meine
hoffnung stirbt langsam dass wir in
diesem wichtigen bereich zu irgendwas
kommen deswegen geben sie sich einen
ruck das thema ist zu drängen meine
damen und herren vielen dank konstantin
von notz war das für uns 90 die grünen
hier im deutschen bundestag
denn bevor die drüsen in dieser debatte
die viel zur sicherheit
informationstechnischer systeme ist
thorsten frei er ist stellvertretender
fraktionsvorsitzender der unionsfraktion
präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen und vielleicht den rahmen noch
etwas größer zu ziehen wir sprechen mit
dem sicherheitsgesetz 2.0 über ein ganz
zentrales sicherheitsgesetz aber nicht
das einzige das wir zum ende dieser
legislaturperiode hier noch durchs
parlament bringen möchten sondern wir
sehen das durchaus in einen größeren
rahmen und werden sicherheit in allen
bestandteilen aus rust agieren
es ist zu recht in dieser debatte
deutlich gemacht worden dass in der
langen vorgeschichte dieses gesetzes ich
höre hier dass wir etwas schnell durchs
parlament peitschen wollten dass es
keine debatte auch in der
zivilgesellschaft und im öffentlichen
raum gegeben hätte nein dieses gesetz
hat eine lange vorgeschichte es ist auch
nur um gelegen sondern es ist breit
diskutiert worden in den
unterschiedlichsten themenbereichen und
dabei war ein thema besonders im
öffentlichen fokus das heißt aber nicht
dass es das einzige gewesen wäre dass
wir bearbeitet hätten im besonderen
öffentlichen interesse war die frage
welche telekommunikationsausrüster
dürfen sich beim aufbau der 5g
infrastruktur in deutschland
heiligen und diese frage auch die frage
ist es möglich dass man eine ex ante
untersagung möglichkeit landschaft wenn
überwiegende öffentliche interessen
dagegen stehen wenn es also vor allem um
sicherheitspolitische interessen der
bundesrepublik deutschland geht dann ist
diese frage mit diesem gesetzentwurf
klar beantwortet und sie deckt sich mit
dem was die regierungsfraktionen union
die spd bereits vor einem jahr in
positionspapieren formuliert hat wir
sind sehr zufrieden mit dem
gesetzentwurf der heute auf dem tisch
des hauses liegt und deswegen ist
vollkommen klar ja wir brauchen die
möglichkeit dass die politik das die
regierung entscheiden kann
wenn elementare sicherheitsinteressen
unseres landes gehört sind auch ex ante
eine solche untersagung zu ermöglichen
und woran liegt s was ist der leitende
gedanke wir haben es beim 5g netz mit
einem system mit einer infrastruktur zu
tun die hochdynamisch ist die komplex
ist und wo die technischen
überwachungsmöglichkeiten eben durchaus
auch begrenzt sind und deswegen müssen
an die sicherheit aber auch an die
vertrauenswürdigkeit ganz besondere
anforderungen gestellt werden
und wir sind auch auf der höhe der zeit
wenn sich nämlich diese untersagung
möglichkeiten auf kritische komponenten
bezieht dann machen wir das nicht
statisch sondern behalten die dynamik
des netzausbaus letztlich im blick indem
wir sagen heute sind periphere netz
keine kritische infrastruktur aber sie
können es im weiteren ausbau des netzes
durchaus werden und es ist
richtigerweise darauf hingewiesen worden
dass ist nur ein bestandteil des it
sicherheits gesetzes wir regeln vieles
andere mehr
und gerade die aktuellen ereignisse der
bundesminister ist darauf eingegangen
die zeigen doch wie notwendig das ist
nicht nur weil wir in zeiten der korona
pandemie merken wie immer mehr das
digitale auch unser gesamtes leben auch
der gesamten bevölkerung durch strömt
wenn wir sicherheit in den netzen nicht
gewährleisten können
dann kostet es enorme summen geld im
monat beispielsweise was haben die
angegriffen in deutschland
stadtverwaltung gerichte krankenhäuser
kritische infrastruktur der schaden in
deutschland nur der der bekannt ist 14,5
millionen weltweit vermutlich
zweieinhalb milliarden euro oder noch
sehr viel mehr
das macht doch deutlich wir müssen in
diesem bereich aufrüsten das ist unsere
verantwortung das ist teil unseres
sicherheitsversprechen sun die menschen
in unserem land und deshalb ist es
richtig dass wir das bsi
unsere technische cyber abwehr behörde
dass wir die massiv gestärkt hat haben
und er höferlin in den letzten fünf
jahren nicht nur verdoppelt haben in der
personenanzahl sondern um 231 prozent
gesteigert haben damit machen wir die
behörde auch fit für die
herausforderungen die jetzt auf sie
zukommen
und das bedeutet noch besseren schutz
nicht nur für die bundesbehörden sondern
insbesondere auch für die gesellschaft
und deshalb gehört das mit dazu dass wir
den verbraucherschutz stärken deshalb
gehört es mit dazu dass wir mit einem
einheitlichen it sicherheitssiegel
letztlich auch die möglichkeit
hecken für verbraucher sich ein bild zu
machen verstärken und wir brauchen
natürlich auf eine bessere
zusammenarbeit der länder
wir brauchen dort
unterstützungsmöglichkeiten weil der
cyberraum sich eben nicht an
ländergrenzen orientiert all das ist in
diesem gesetzentwurf drin
deswegen ist es ein guter gesetzentwurf
den werden wir jetzt gemeinsam beraten
aber ich bin absolut zuversichtlich dass
wir das hinkriegen in gemeinsam auch
zügig durchs parlament zu bringen
herzlichen dank die soweit thorsten frei
hier in der debatte im deutschen
bundestag wir schauen weiter mit einem
kleinen auge auch zum
untersuchungsausschuss wo weiterhin wir
erwarten dass bundesverkehrsminister
scheuer vor die mikrofone tritt und der
letzte redner hier im deutschen
bundestag zu dieser debatte ist falko
mohrs geehrte frau präsidentin meine
damen und herren ja wir sind abhängig in
deutschland abhängig vom funktionieren
unserer infrastruktur abhängig davon
dass insbesondere kritische
infrastrukturen wie unser energienetz
oder das telekommunikationsnetz
funktionieren und trotz natürlich aller
sicherheitsmaßnahmen in form von
redundanzen und plan b bedarf es eben
gerade im bereich der cyber sicherheit
der it nach einer zusätzlichen
anstrengung um unsere sicherheit und
unsere kritischen infrastrukturen hierzu
schützt meine damen und herren und sehe
ist er krank wurden herzlichen dank
dafür
und wenn wir eben genau diese
infrastrukturen schützen wollen insider
bereich dann ist ja eben auch schon zur
sprache gekommen wurden wie sich
eigentlich die bedrohungslage in den
letzten jahren massiv verändert hat mir
dann auch behauptet wird von einigen es
gebe keine evidenz gar keine betrachtung
der lage oder wie
ich eigentlich dass ausgewirkt habe was
in den letzten jahren dort eben sich
entwickelt hat ist das völlig falsch
dann lesen sie offensichtlich den jedes
jahr wiederkommen lagebericht des bsi
zum beispiel überhaupt nicht denn dort
würden sie sehen in welche richtung sich
die entwicklung der bedrohung
tatsächlich ergeben hat oder würden sie
auch begreifen dass das was hier mit dem
gesetz heute vorgelegt wird eine gute
eine wichtige antwort auf diese
veränderte bedrohungslage ist meine
damen und herren
und wir haben und wird tatsächlich in
einem bereich sozusagen wenn es um das
nervensystem unserer infrastruktur geht
wenn es um die telekommunikation wenn es
eben um 5 g
die fünfte mobilfunk generation geht in
der tat sehr intensiv und hart gerungen
ich hätte mir manchmal auch gewünscht es
wäre weniger öffentlich gewesen ich
hätte mir an vielen stellen gewünscht es
wäre deutlich schneller gegangen aber
wir haben jetzt am ende an den weg
vorgelegte sagte es gibt eben beides es
gibt auf der einen seite eine technische
überprüfung der kritischen komponenten
das heißt das eben nicht einfach
geglaubt wird was irgendwo vorgelegt
wird und es wird technisch überprüft
weil wir aber eben der festen
überzeugung sind dass in dem umfang
beispielsweise der software mit
millionen von zahlen von codes die
vorgelegt werden eben nicht alles
technische wird prüfbar ist gibt es eben
daneben gestellt eine
vertrauenswürdigkeit wird von eine
politische überprüfung und das meine
damen und herren ist ein wichtiges
element was wir in der debatte in den
letzten anderthalb jahren erreicht haben
und deswegen und deswegen bin ich auch
froh dass ich manche dann hier dafür
applaudieren lassen die in den letzten
tagen war zwei jahren nicht immer die
vorkämpfer für diese maßnahme seien ich
finde es aber gut dass wir am ende das
in den gesetzentwurf hineingeschrieben
meine damen und herren wir schaffen also
hier mit diesem gesetzentwurf eine gute
grundlage für die beratungen
parlamentarisches verfahren
herr von notz wir nehmen bestimmt gute
vorschläge gerne auf die an den
kritischen blick ja vielleicht schon die
richtige richtung geben gewendet weniger
gute vorschläge werden bei ihm nicht
aufnehmen so ist das nun mal im leben
aber meine damen und herren ich bin mir
sicher dass es uns gelingen wird mit dem
parlamentarischen anstehenden beratungen
hier ein gutes update für das alte
sicherheitsgesetz vorzulegen ich freue
mich auf die beratung herzlichen dank
vielen dank ich schieße die aussprache